[Musique]
le collectif de la saugrenue est une
association loi de 1901 création est
diffusion le contenu à travers tout le
Centre-Val de Loire 50 musiciens un
technicien professionnel musique de
manière universelle influence musicale
de tout horizon et c'est parti pour la
20e saison
[Musique]
comment ça fait plaisir le but est bon
je l'ai déjà dit il y a des années
merci merci d'asso grenouille il se
passe des trucs incroyables ici Flo faut
que tu me racontes ton histoire ton
parcours comment tu as commencé
l'accordéon comment tu es arrivé ici à
la saudrenue ah ouais d'accordéon j'ai
commencé ce que j'ai mon papa il était
batteur dans un groupe de balles et puis
bah un jour ils ont changé dans leur
groupe d'accordéoniste et là il y en
avait un qui était là et j'ai flashé
dessus je me suis dit c'est ça que je
veux faire quoi alors l'état d'esprit de
la sauce grenouille comment tu le
définirais et ben la saugrenue justement
là on avait appelé comme ça aussi parce
que l'idée c'était d'aller mélanger des
gens qui normalement se rencontrent pas
par exemple des gens qui font du musette
avec des gens qui font du dub un truc
complètement saugrenu il faut que je te
présente quelqu'un avec qui joue c'est
Renaud détruit
Elvis Presley
c'est pour toi mon gars
tu arrives quand ici toi
quelqu'un entendu parler du collectif
[Musique]
c'était des copains
on s'est rencontré sur les bancs de la
fac et donc le 38e parallèle c'est quand
même un lieu fascinant qui permet
vraiment de répéter travailler et
d'aboutir des projets exactement c'est
pour développer des projets artistiques
et puis c'est un lieu qui foisonne de
création culturelle j'adore le son de
cet instrument tu peux nous faire un
petit truc là un petit riff là à toi
[Musique]
magique Gilles où est-ce que tu
m'emmènes pour la suite et ben on va
aller voir Océane
[Musique]
ah oui
j'ai commencé à écrire des chansons et à
poser en fait mes mots dessus et c'est
comme ça au départ je voulais pas du
tout être chanteuse c'était vraiment je
voulais juste voilà voir un support pour
mes textes bon les amis on se quitte
avec quoi là
j'ai dans la cabochette comme une envie
me marrer j'ai dans l'interroche
la conclusion
ne l'émission la sauver une musique qui
vient de dodorisant c'était calme avec
les bananes
[Musique]